[Música]
vamos ahora con las noticias de economía
de la mano de Daniela hablandona Daniela
Buen día para usted Hola Buenos días
Ángela Hoy es un día importante para los
franceses qué es lo que les molesta de
la Reforma pensional pues mire el
presidente Manuel macron enfrenta su
mayor desacuerdo con los sindicatos
desde que llegó al poder en 2017 y ya
acumula seis jornadas de movilizaciones
masivas por cuenta de una reforma que se
considera decisiva para ambas partes
tanto para los ciudadanos como para El
Ejecutivo de Manuel macron y vamos a ver
por qué lo que más ha disgustado a los
franceses es que va a Elevar la edad
mínima de pensión gradualmente desde los
62 años actuales poniendo al país más en
línea con sus vecinos de la Unión
Europea la mayoría de los cuales ha
[__] la edad a 65 años o más hoy
esta nación como vemos acá tiene uno de
los pisos de edad más cortos si se
compara con otros países como Suecia o
con Alemania la Unión Europea en general
España Países Bajos o Italia y Inclusive
la proyección muestra que todos estos
países van a tener una edad de pensión
mucho más alta que Francia en de aquí a
2070 hay que decir también que ya en
2010 Nicolás sarcosy había subido la
edad de pensión de los franceses desde
los 60 a los 62 años actuales igual
Daniel es que no es fácil devolverse en
derechos que uno ha ganado como
trabajador no pero vamos a ver qué otros
puntos aparte de la edad son los que
están en juego en esta reforma entonces
la ley también aboliría los privilegios
especiales que disfrutan algunos
empleados del sector público por ejemplo
estamos hablando de los del metro de
París La idea es que para 2032 quienes
se jubilen tengan que cotizar durante 43
años de su vida Aunque habría
excepciones como lo ha dicho el mismo
gobierno por ejemplo quienes cursen
carreras de larga duración o también
quienes tengan trabajos muy pesados los
cambios también supondrían pequeños
aumentos para las pensiones más bajas
concretamente un 85% del salario mínimo
sería lo mínimo con lo que una persona
se jubilaría lo cual bueno digamos que
no está tan mal dentro de todo qué
Argumenta el gobierno Entonces es
bastante impopular Ángela esta propuesta
inicialmente se dijo que el objetivo era
hacer el sistema más justo pero ahora el
gobierno enfatiza en que se trata de
ahorro pues estima que en la próxima
década va a haber unos 160.000 millones
de dólares en déficit acumulado si el
sistema sigue operando como está
operando hasta ahora eso es lo que es
más difícil de hacerle entender a la
población Angela y pues el gobierno ha
hecho de énfasis en que lo que quiere es
tratar de evitar el colapso del sistema
Estatal de pensiones y garantizar que
aquellas generaciones más jóvenes pues
no carguen con esa responsabilidad de
financiar a las mayores macron ha
pronunciado varias veces una frase que
es bastante impopular Y es que él dice
hay que trabajar más de alguna manera
las encuestas dicen que dos tercios de
los votantes Están en contra de estos
cambios que entrarían en vigencia en
septiembre si es que pasan el examen
parlamentario complicado Cuál es el
estado del proyecto Entonces en este
momento pues el proyecto básicamente
Busca apresurar el gobierno mejor Está
tratando de apresurar la aprobación en
la asamblea nacional a más tardar a
finales de este mes entraría entonces en
vigencia si así sucede en septiembre
próximo Aunque el partido centrista de
macron no tiene una mayoría en la cámara
baja si Confía en que pueda contar con
el apoyo de los republicanos de derecha
en ambas cámaras esto para asegurar las
mayorías necesarias para pasar sacar
adelante este proyecto Y esperan que El
Avance sea dentro de marzo por aquí ya
terminamos con esta explicación sobre la
reforma francesa por la cual le
agradezco mucho Daniela y ahora quisiera
que habláramos del mercado financiero
mundial el que tiene su mirada puesta
sobre el presidente de la reserva
Federal Por qué razón pues Ángela algo
pasa muy si Y es que cada palabra que
pronunciar un Powell es analizada con
pinzas por el mercado financiero siempre
que él sale a dar alguna declaración el
mercado financiero está muy alerta todo
porque en este momento podría dar luces
sobre los siguientes pasos que va a dar
o que va a tomar la reserva Federal en
lo que tiene que ver con tasas de
interés que es un tema bastante sensible
en este momento recordemos que la
reserva Federal ha venido subiendo sus
tasas de interés Durante los últimos
meses para frenar el consumo y de esta
manera pues hacer bajar la inflación una
estrategia que también hemos llevado acá
en América Latina pues después de casi
nueve meses el jefe de la Fed comparece
hoy ante el comité bancario del senado
mañana lo hará ante el comité de
servicios financieros de la cámara y
Todos quieren saber si se mantiene en su
postura de que el país ya comenzó un
proceso desinflacionario es decir que la
inflación se está desacelerando y eso
haría pensar que los próximos aumentos
en las tasas de interés no van a ser tan
agresivos Pero qué pasa que las cosas
han cambiado desde que él emitió su más
reciente proyección a comienzos de año
porque la inflación no está bajando
tanto como se quiere y por eso la
expectativa de hoy gira en torno hacia
él cree que está funcionando esa
estrategia de encarecer más esos
créditos o si hay que moverse en otra
dirección cualquier palabra que diga va
a ser interpretada de diferentes maneras
por el mercado financiero seguramente
mañana me estará contando Así es hasta
yo tendré mi propia interpretación de lo
que diga el Señor pues aquí la espero
con ese tema Mientras tanto vamos a
hablar de chile que regresó a la
corporación andina de fomento pues la
corporación andina de fomento o la caf
también se conoce como la caf es un
banco multilateral constituido en 1970
está conformado por 20 países 18 son de
América Latina y el Caribe también por
España y Portugal y además 13 bancos
privados de la región y su función es
proporcionar financiamiento tanto en
forma de créditos como en cooperación
pues chile había salido como miembro
pleno durante la dictadura de Augusto
pinochet y había mantenido un estatus de
asociado Ahora va a ser miembro pleno de
esta corporación andina de fomento según
dijo el presidente Gabriel boriche
escuchemos
la integración no es solo verborrea la
integración latinoamericana no son solo
adjetivos la integración latinoamericana
no son solamente discursos
es trabajo serio persistente en el
tiempo y a mí me alegra y me enorgullece
que chile en esta dimensión en la
dimensión de la caf vuelva como bien
decía Juan Manuel Santos
a vuelva a casa nos queda su cifrada del
día bueno Vámonos un poco de la región
hasta el Asia porque 2.900 millones de
dólares es lo que es Irlanda espera en
aprobación final de un del fondo
monetario internacional para obtener un
préstamo por este valor en la tercera o
cuarta semana de este mes así lo dijo el
presidente del país serranel que
messinge quien aseguró que china también
dará apoyo adicional recordemos que este
país asiático de 22 millones de
habitantes se enfrentado y su peor
crisis económica desde la independencia
de Gran Bretaña en 1948 Gracias por esa
cifra la dejamos pendiente porque usted
y yo vamos a hablar del tema de
endeudamiento de los países con nuestro
siguiente invitado del día sí señor aquí
estaré hasta entonces